Speaker 1: Speaking of the 2022 election, Rolling
Stone has an incredible report out about the Trump
plan. It's an active plan to try to steal the 2022
election. Now, you might be saying, well, steal
it. Steal it in what way? Because Republicans may
do quite well in the 2022 election. Rolling Stone
reports that Donald Trump has, quote, convened a
series of in-person meetings and conference calls
to discuss laying the groundwork to challenge
the 2022 midterm election results. During these
meetings and these conference calls, quote,
pro-Trump groups, attorneys, Republican Party
activists and MAGA diehards often discuss the type
of scorched earth legal tactics they could deploy.
Now, this is for elections. They don't win
specifically. Understand that this is not about
let's come together. It sounds so stupid because
it's so unbelievable. Let's come to let's do
something good for democracy. Let's come together
to ensure that the rightful winner, as determined
by the will of the people, actually wins every
single election. That's my Tucker Carlson
laugh. Ha, ha. That's not what they want. That's
not what they want. This is for elections. They
don't win. Let's figure out what sort of tactics
we can use to try to get some of these anyway.
They came close in 2020 and they're not giving
up. One route that they reportedly plan to take,
says Rolling Stone, is to do the exact same thing
on election night that Trump tried in those early
hours of the 2020 election, which is you come
out and you say there has been fraud or fraud,
as Trump says, I won. This is embarrassing. We're
winning this election. And remember, frankly,
we did win this election. Those chilling words at
2 a.m. where you didn't win anything. What are you
talking about? Frankly, we did win this election.
That is one tool that they are looking to employ,
maybe with more favorable district courts,
secretaries of state, governors, etc.. The
report from Rolling Stone is that Trump is very
focused on Pennsylvania, including Oz v Fetterman.
We already talked extensively about that race
earlier and the internal dynamics of that race.
Why would Trump care so much about Pennsylvania?
It should be obvious at this point. 2024
is the reason why in 2024, Pennsylvania could
determine who is the next president of the
United States. And certainly having your guy in
as a senator who could potentially object to the
counting of the electoral votes in the in January
of 2025 is useful. Also, having a governor in Doug
Mastriano, who chooses the secretary of State
who oversees the election in 2024 would be very,
very useful. I'm increasingly wondering what,
if any, connection there is between the armed
intimidators outside of Arizona ballot boxes and
this Trump movement? I don't know. I'm just asking
the question. And what you have to understand is
that at the end of the day, their proposals make
no sense. They don't have that many options left.
But to cheat and steal. Look at some of the things
they're proposing. A national abortion ban that's
completely unpopular at a time when Roe v Wade is
as popular as it has been over a 50 year period.
Now you're going to say national abortion ban.
That doesn't make sense. So instead, you go to
cheating and stealing, doing nothing about gun
violence and actually proposing more guns in
more places despite constant mass shootings.
That doesn't make a lot of sense. So then you go
to, well, we can cheat and we can steal looking at
gutting and cutting Social Security and Medicare.
When older voters are demographically their bread
and butter, that doesn't make sense. So you
figure out ways to cheat and steal. If they can
get away with it, they're going to try. Or rather,
I should say they're going to try and they may be
able to get away with it. And if you want to get
a sense of the level of delusion here, let's go
to Jon Stewart's incredible interview that is
going to be published in full very, very soon